mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
madame le ministre du travail à qui je
souhaite un prompt rétablissement
madame le ministre votre gouvernement a
décidé de reprendre la main sur le
pilotage de l'apprentissage au niveau
national en supprimant toute régulation
fonctions qui étaient exercées par les
régions aujourd'hui l'association des
régions de france tire la sonnette
d'alarmé en attirant l'attention sur
l'évolution des choix de l'orientation
sur les métiers qui tend à accentuer une
inéquation entre l'offre et la demande
sur le marché du travail ce qui ne va
pas dans le sens de régler le problème
crucial des postes non pourvus
madame le ministre allez-vous prendre
cette situation en compte et redonner
une compétence de régulation région qui
en raison de leur compétence économique
pourrait travailler avec les branches
professionnelles et anticiper en
orientant les choix de formation sur les
métiers créateur d'emplois aujourd'hui
la réalité est que les entreprises
peinent à recruter les candidats à
l'apprentissage se retrouve devant de
multiples interlocuteurs et ont du mal à
entrer dans le dispositif les apprentis
les plus défavorisés ont besoin d'un
accompagnement pour trouver un employeur
trouver un le mans trouver un
hébergement et faire des démarches pour
obtenir les aides nécessaires et pour
finir où en êtes vous avec les
négociations qui doivent s'engager avec
les régions de france pour les
compensations qui d'après les comptes
vous leur devez